alors jacques fournier visiter comme ça
la maison de la poésie avec cette saab
qui est assez unique puisque il ya
combien de places 75 places maximum
ça va donner un cadreur qui adore la
poésie souvent guillaume chez nous bah
oui guillaume on s'assied oui
profitons-en donc vous diriger cette
maison de la poésie depuis depuis son
origine de nous en faisons c'est que
c'est quand même assez extraordinaire
avant il n'y a pas il n'a pas 50 buts et
maison de la poésie en france n'ont
hélas si on n'a pas assez il ya on va
dire une vingtaine de lieux en france
qui peuvent se définir comme étant des
maisons de poésie que ce soit à
marseille avignon qui sont les plus
anciens montpellier rennes nantes paris
et d'autres un poitiers etc une
vingtaine de lieux mais cette maison
elle a une grande particularité ici
c'est que c'est une volonté politique
toutes les autres maisons de poésie en
france sont des associations des
volontés d'associations de collectifs
etc ici on est en régie directe et on
dépend de la direction de la culture de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est une
vraie volonté politique d'inscrire la
poésie dans la glace sur du de la cité
il ya une raison historique oui c'était
alors d'ados qui est président et ancien
ancien maire de dre de guyancourt ancien
président de saint quentin qui est peut
être lui mais il veut être plus vert
voilà il ya mis de la maison et
régulièrement présent ici pour nous
soutenir aussi est là c'est une chose
formidable et en même temps est-ce que
c'est pas une contradiction au fond une
institutionnalisation de la poésie on
assure l'impression que la poésie c'est
quelque chose qui est un qu'il a peu
contre les institutions contre la
délinquance c'est pourquoi des lieux et
à quoi il sert des nues en entendant
parler avec nos collègues c'est vrai
qu'on se pose la question mais dire la
limite pourquoi pas c'est bien d'être
dans la place bien sûr et de défendre de
défendre notre présence dans cette place
au milieu des autres formes de faut
savoir que la poésie quand même la plus
ancienne forme de création monde
s'il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas être
soutenus par des institutions sous
prétexte que voilà les poètes où ils
dissidents oui révolte et oui bien sûr
ça n'empêche pas la révolte vaut mieux
être à l'intérieur de la de la citadelle
pour pour en parler c'est quand on est
dehors on nous entend pas est ce que en
tant que directeur de la maison de la
poésie vous avez une liberté absolue
ah oui vous avez des contraintes la
contrainte la contrainte elle existe
puisque il ya une politique culturelle
forte sur saint quentin qui s'affirme de
plus en plus et on est tout à fait
favorable à cela je d'abord bon je suis
fonctionnaire de la poésie comme je dis
ici en m'amusant mais pour ce qui est de
la programmation c'est liberté totale et
j'ai toujours défendu cette liberté je
défendrai cette liberté c'est à dire que
voilà quand je suis arrivé ici en
personne entre guillemets je dis ça
souvent sous forme de boutade ne savait
quoi mettre dans cette maison moi je
suis arrivé avec un dossier j'ai pas
fait le tiers de ce que j'ai envisagé
dedans et j'ai fait tout ce que je
voulais faire mais donc il ya encore
plein de choses à faire passer par
exemple de défendre des résidences
d'écrivains l'ex-résidence de poètes sur
le territoire on est en train de
travailler à cela comment on fait alors
de vue quand on est entré dans cette
maison elle est au coeur de la ville le
fokker duckling guyancourt oui dans un
quartier un peu commerçants il ya enfin
la c1 il y avait un côté et comment on
fait pour attirer la publier sur est ce
qu'il faut c'est pas est-ce qu'il faut
la pâte est ce qu'il faut vous commencez
par des choses faciles pour l'algérie
cible sur cette maison c'est je dis
simplement je ne veux pas remplir la
coquille pour le plaisir de la remplir
on travaille énormément hors les murs on
travaille avec tous les partenaires
possibles sur le territoire de saint
quentin et même au delà avec le soutien
du conseil général dans le cadre du
festival poésie yvelines la semaine des
poètes c'est à dire qu'on est partout je
mets des poètes partout on allie des
poètes dans des salons de coiffure dans
des clubs de sport dans des braderies
voilà on est dans la rue on veut en
sorte que les poètes soit à l'extérieur
et que toute personne un jour se disent
tiens j'ai entendu un poème dans ma vie
est ce ça que je veux je veux pas faire
des chiffres ici en disant on a rempli à
90 % à 100 % de spectacles nos soirées
etc non le but c'est que les gens
rencontrent les habitants de saint
quentin et des environs est ailleurs
rencontre un jour dans leur vie
l'apologie le poème est le poète c'est
une sorte d'utopie que de vouloir faire
en sorte que la poésie soit entendu par
tous c'est sans cette utopie on ne
vivrait pas et sans cette utopie je
ferai pas ce boulot là vous êtes vous
même vous parler un petit peu de vous
poète vous êtes d'abord un enseignant
oui pour autant ce port breton
breton évoluons le breton est un oui il
faut heureusement breton une bourguignon
c'est quand même assez bad ouais mais
comment vous est venue à la poésie
qu'est ce qui vous a l'amour quand on
est adolescent on est amoureux alors on
écrit des poèmes écrits square et puis
mes profs pour draguer donc non non non
pas pour draguer n'ont même pas mal
c'était même pas pour draguer ça donne
une sorte d'état des lieux et surtout
mes proches j'ai eu deux enseignants au
lycée monsieur wartel et monsieur
antoine que je remercie tous les jours
de m'avoir mis devant un poème et de
m'avoir mis le pied à l'étrier et un
autre enseignant que j'ai rencontrés
quand j'étais à l'école normale à douai
c'est pierre herlant qui est peut être
lui-même et ces gens là je les remercie
tous les jours de de m'avoir fait voilà
de m'avoir aidé on se fait on se fait
dans sa vie on se fait en france va de
laissant avec tout ce que l'on vit on va
pas rentrer dans le détail voilà il la
poésie a été pour moi un refuge donc
j'ai lu je j'écumais la bibliothèque du
quartier à trouver des livres je ne
comprenais pas tout j'écoutais des
choses j'avais des profs moi qui me
faisais écouter on nous faisait les
bandes son des boum avec des gens comme
léo ferré jean ferrat jacques brel vont
danser là dessus on vous dit pas ça ça
s'arrange alors ça fait rentrer des
textes étaient rentrés vers l'est
napoléon
voilà donc on voit là c'est le bain que
j'ai eu moi adolescent et puis après
avec les copains lancer une petite
maison d'édition vos premières émotions
valent les premiers poètes que vous
aimez et ceux qui sont encore
aujourd'hui dans votre rôle et le à
rions pas les lois paul eluard pendant
des années je me promenais avec un
recueil de paul eluard sur bois géants
capables de retenir un poème j'ai pas de
mémoire pour nous mais je lisais j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup lui paul
eluard
à la mosquée pendant très longtemps qui
est un personnage un peu oublié
maintenant qui était une sorte de
parangon de la poésie très parisien mais
des oeuvres très très belle et des
romans aussi magnifiques unes mais
russell un magnifique
voilà c'était les deux un peu mon
panthéon mais y en a plein d'autres donc
donc une poésie contemporaine enfin oui
c'est très 20e moi j'ai 26 ans
j'ai beaucoup de mal avec la poésie 19e
je me plonge dedans là j'ai fait un
montage de lecture par exemple pour
daniel mesguich trait au domaine de
madame elisabeth et un autre montage
pour marie christine barrault une
troisième qu'on a fait sur la scène ça
m'a permis de me plonger dans la poésie
du 19e siècle donc d'aller rechercher
des choses des textes chez sheila martin
chez hugo mais qui est considéré plutôt
comme le vois comme ça comme le grand
cirque de la poésie enfin avec des
c'était le grand siècle de la pause est
le 20e sont intéressés le remarquable
parce que justement lundi le 20e est
remarquable parce que justement il ya eu
sept explosions mais cette explosion
complètement en phase avec le le
quotidien l'histoire la guerre 14 18 a
donné naissance à dada et au surréalisme
le la guerre 39-45 a donné naissance au
poète de la résistance seghers n'aurait
pas été seghers s'il n'y avait pas eu la
résistance et la pile de travail que
fait seghers avec les poètes du xxème
siècle n'aurait jamais été ce qu'il a
été et l'engagement des poètes dans ses
dires là et on l'a vu aux etats-unis
aussi dans les années 50 avec la beat
generation l'engagement dans les années
60 70 des poètes contre la guerre du
vietnam l'engagement à des poètes
algériens c'était on a travaillé en a
publié une anthologie de poètes
algériens contemporain on a produit une
lecture de textes de poètes qui ont
fondé la poésie de langue française en
algérie les poètes des années 50 et des
années 60 c'est incroyable travail
qu'ils ont fait des gens comme jean
sénac sont complètement en phase et
c'est le 20e siècle est un grand siècle
de la poésie et vous parlez de vous
parler de cette guerre est ce que des
gens comme ces gars qui ont fait
énormément élections est ce que ça ne
manque pas aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
revues il ya eu de yennenga 1350 euros
très une vie très riche oui un ferry
mais mais mais qui reste dans un cercle
importance avec ces gars et il a eu ce
mérite là si oui il a eu ce mérite mais
ce qu'ils vendaient beaucoup n'ont pas
donc pas plus pas plus que les éditeurs
de maintenant et on en parle beaucoup à
a posteriori avec du recul on s était
important c'était bien il ya des maisons
d'édition qui fait un travail
remarquable
le monde et au delà des éditions du des
bleus qui ont été dirigés par louis du
beau pendant plus de 35 ans a fait un
travail remarquable de découverte de
jeunes poètes et d'affirmation de
quelqu'un comme pierre autin grenier a
d'abord été publiée au des bleus par
exemple quelqu'un comme valérie rosoux
qui est maintenant est une des voix les
plus importants de la poésie
contemporaine
sophie l'oiseau qui est publié chez
flammarion ce sont des gens qui sont
passés dans des maisons qui les ont fait
émerger après le travail de gallimard de
flammarion celle entretenue à ça voilà
mais ce travail existe encore on en
parle moi parce que c'est pas médiatisé
mais seghers n'était pas médiatisés on
n'en parlait pas
fondés nous à la réflexion voilà on
allait chercher des nez dans les
bouquineries mais on n'en parlait pas
mais maintenant il existe des dizaines
et des dizaines de maisons d'édition je
parle que des françaises ont parlé en
belgique en suisse au québec c'est un
président c'est vrai que ça fourmille
mais sa forme il vous vous même vous
êtes publiés oui j'ai quelques petites
plaquettes voilà que j'écris très peu
chez un chat gros fainéant pour ça mais
on ne prend pas le temps d'écrire je
m'occupe trop de la police grisonne
c'est pas un frein à la création oui ça
ferait là c'est un énorme frein il ya le
temps mais il ya peut-être aussi le
faible d'oeuvre la des autres est ce que
c'est impressionnant aussi parfois
simplement parce que moi j'écrivais déjà
j'écrivais je lisais beaucoup
contrairement à beaucoup de poètes que
disait louis dubos faut déjà que les
poètes lisent les poètes et les maisons
d'édition sera très riche c'est vrai oui
parce qu'il valait peut être moi je
lisais les poètes et écrivains j'ai
aucun aucun complexe j'aurais pas plus
de complexes maintenant disons que je
n'ai plus est cette veine là je m'occupe
beaucoup d autres je fais des notes de
lecture je fais des articles
j'interviens dans des colloques voilà je
parle de la poésie des autres jeux là je
ne mets pas du tout la mienne en avant
chez publié 3 4 4 petites plaquettes de
poésie avec beaucoup de plaisir à
chercher des de bon éditeur en plus
voilà mais c'est pas dominant dans mon
travail est-ce qu'il ya déjà de gens qui
viennent vous voir d or alive
j'écris ça on a des papas qui viennent
nous voir pas trop mais on reçoit par
mail beaucoup des propositions des
textes on conseille moi je suis on est
on est ensemble de ressources dès qu'on
peut vous écrire voilà pas complètement
mais moi je réponds j'ai un principe
c'est que je réponds tu étais pas dans
la seconde mais je réponds c'est à dire
qu'on accompagne des poètes par exemple
ont accompagné une jeune poète qui
habitent dans les yvelines s'appelle
mediapad elec on l'a soutenu petit à
petit en lui donnant un petit peu plus
de plus en plus la parole un de ses
livres a été publié aux éditions le
bruit des autres et pas la dernière
édition en est son livre est
sélectionné pour le prix poésie vie des
collégiens que nous organisons dans tout
le département auprès des collégiens
voilà donc on fait un travail de soutien
comme ça je pense à quelqu'un comme au
collectif uppercut me dit sont issus de
la scène slam on va pas évoquer las le
slam ici parce qu'on en a pour deux
heures mais c'est à choisi ce nom c'est
une forme actuellement pas c'est surtout
pas c'est une prise de parole et c'est
bien après donc ils sont issus de la
presse que l'ondé font leur travail
c'est vrai qu'à cette confusion c'est
bien tout le disiez parce qu'il ya un
mois sa foi dans le public une confusion
entre voilà pour vous la poésie c'est
plate forme c'est surtout pas une forme
on en revient chez mon boucher tout le
monde parce que ça arrive voilà voilà ça
fait pas le poème
il va falloir quitter malheureuse glace
ça fait un peu plus de dix ans donc vous
êtes à la tête de cette maison il vous
faudrait combien de temps pour arriver
à ce que vous voudriez faire mais devra
que ma vie ne suffirait pas
pour longtemps
pour moi qui décide quoi que quand même
je décide quand même de mon de mon
avenir non je crois qu'on a toujours des
choses à faire et puis il faut toujours
remettre le couvert quoi il faut
remettre voilà le louvre âge sur le sur
l'établi et retravaillé auprès des
différentes personnes que l'on rencontre
les convaincre parfois on en oublie on
travaille énormément dans le milieu
scolaire on n'en a pas parlé on
accompagne une vingtaine de projets dans
l'année de la maternelle à l'université
mais il faut renouveler toujours auprès
des jeunes mais aussi auprès des adultes
et ça c'est tout notre travail ici c'est
ça qui fait la passion de ce métier
merci beaucoup je vais ressembler crise